di a due lettini e ombrellone io le
posso dare uno sdraio in quattordicesima
fila l'ultimo proprio e mi rimane certo
il mare lo vede perché siamo al mare è
un po laterale nel senso che lei è più
vicina al parcheggio che al bagnasciuga
senti ti faccio 80 euro fino alle 19
guardo appena tavolucci mostra io siamo
al completo e mi dispiace ma che se
grillo che tu sei il figlio del pettine
me lo dici così mi si sono appena
liberati due lettini e un ombrellone in
seconda fila fino ai signori la seconda
fila cambi 30 euro e non ne parliamo più
ma è ovvio oggi domani dopodomani 30
euro 10 euro al giorno regalato è che tu
vuoi la password del wifi senti e lido
pinuccia che sarei io 66 santa non è
l'età leggilo vita mi dispiace il bagno
lei solo per i clienti ossia dei clienti
private le problema ecco le chiavi mi
raccomando riportate mele che queste si
perdano come la vostra dignità al sabato
sera